then there's summer camps on Monday but
change programming this year to
incorporate more academics we saw that
we could fill a need and we wanted to
jump in five community centers in the
valley now offer Vegas strong summer
academy it replaces a traditional summer
camp by including more science
technology engineering and math or stem
lessons the city wanted to address the
projected achievement gap due to kovat
closures and the Summer Slide that's
when students forget what's already been
taught because they are out of school we
knew that there was going to be some
delay and just on how impacted kids in
general so we knew we at the city knew
we want to jump in to make sure that we
were there as a resource to parents we
are continued and committed to meet the
challenges at last week's Nevada Board
of Education meeting CCSD superintendent
dr. hey-zeus Jarra said data shows
reading loss for students at 70% and
possibly more from math the district is
offering online learning opportunities
this summer but camps like this aim to
blend the academics with helping
children grow socially and emotionally
through various activities really to get
them out and give them a sense of
normalcy it the academies run Monday
through Friday between 6:30 in the
morning and 6:00 at night through August
7th the cost is $75 a week per child and
scholarships are available
Kristen Drummond 8 News now